[Music]
while wiring up your api runtime with
proxies is a big step in an api's
lifecycle
it marks the beginning of a larger
effort to drive awareness adoption
and usage now let's talk about how you
an api provider
can publish this functionality in order
to attract and engage the people
who develop the apps that use your api
these developers
are your consumers you can create a
great experience for your consumers
using apogee's api publishing tools and
developer portals
whether your apis are meant for internal
or external use
or both a great developer experience
requires an intuitive catalog of apis
detailed documentation for each of those
products
and an easy onboarding process let's see
how those work
here's an api i can see the request and
response format
and i can see that this api uses an api
key for security
that's really valuable after seeing the
api documentation
the next step a developer will want to
take is to get credentials that allows
their app
to access that api the developer portal
provides that too
a consumer can just register and sign in
using their credentials
or you the provider can delegate that
authentication step to your company's
single sign-on service or sso using saml
once i've signed in i can see my client
applications listed for me
though at first i don't have any so
let's create one
clicking through i can then manage the
products authorized for that app
now i can see my new api key so fast and
easy
now let's try the interactive
documentation again paste in my api key
and it works all right here within the
developer portal
this really helps developers get started
rapidly
and of course there are tools that an
api publisher can use to easily
customize the portal to match their
brand guidelines
clicking through this page gives access
to the theme and styling
the portal pages various settings and
assets like images and so on
and here i can add my api products to
the catalog
a developer portal is a key part of an
api program and this is just a taste of
how it works
an apigee developer portal helps your
developers discover
explore test and learn so they can build
on top of your apis quickly
and securely
[Music]
you